good morning believe nation today's
message is add value over to you Peter
sage
if we understand that for the majority
of people on the planet money is nothing
more than a reflection of the value that
they've added then we start to
understand that you know what has to
come first is the value not going around
chasing money if you chase money you'll
chase your tail because you're chasing
the consequence of something that hasn't
happened yet
that makes sense so if you look at it
under that context then you know how do
you start a business with no money well
you don't ask yourself where do I get
money you ask yourself a better question
you say where is it that I can add value
how can I add value what is it that I
can contribute that would cause somebody
to be able to give me what it is that I
want without just shelling out a wad of
cash yeah that's the easy way that's you
know all money is as an arbitrary medium
of exchange to measure different levels
of value that's pretty much it so if we
don't have access to money then what we
have to do is come up with ways we can
add value and therefore we shortcut the
process I love this message I've been
talking about a lot on this channel if
you want to make money you got to
provide value you want to make a lot of
money provide a lot of value provide a
lot of money quickly create a lot of
value quickly value is at the core of
every successful business the thing that
would add to it though is adding in
passion how do you provide the value
it's gonna come from doing something
that you're excited about the only way
you get to be the best in your industry
the best in the world at what you do
is because you really love it you're
obsessed about it you stay up late
thinking about it you go to sleep
thinking about what projects you can
work on to make it just a little bit
better right it's that passion that's
gonna feel you so the passion leads to
the skills leads to the value leads to
the money so my question of the day for
you guys today is how do you add value
for your customers I'd love to hear it I
love for you to share that in the
comments below and I think that could
also help inspire some thinking for
other people who are watching how they
maybe will provide value to their
customers so share in the comments below
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of vinspresso
let's pray so give me go